vous invite à aller voir sur les
républicains point fr notre programme
est en ligne donc nous avons beaucoup de
candidats et un seul programme donc oui
mais je pense que notre le programme du
parti sera le socle de travail pour
notre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle le 4 décembre il sera
désigné par notre formation en passant
cette date nadine morano est ce que ce
n'est pas suicidaire d'attendre jusqu'au
4 décembre mais c'est énorme et ça c'est
vous savez ces actes et maintenant les
ados lance des nations non mais je vous
ai présenté comme une voix libre je vous
demande ce que vous pensez de cette date
est ce que le 4 décembre ce n'est pas
laissé le temps ayant exercé de manière
hégémonique sur la droite non choc non
non mais vous savez je crois que le
débat a son importance une immigration
mal maîtrisée nous amène à avoir des
quartiers où vous avez pratiquement en
france des quartiers avec du rien à voir
19 selon l'insee je crois une quinzaine
vous aviez 50% d'étrangers une adhésion
séance législative qui fait que nous
avons une immigration qui est
incontrôlée donc nous avons dans notre
arsenal législatif les moyens de
contrôler cette immigration nous devons
aussi changer ce qu'on appelle le ccda
le code d'entrée et de séjour des
étrangers et du droit d'asile par
exemple rien que sur les mineurs non
accompagnés
ils n'ont pas besoin de titre de séjour
pour s est chez nous vous savez que la
loi européenne la directive retour
permet le renvoi des mineurs non
accompagnés
il n'y a que la france l'italie et le
luxembourg qui ne le faut et qui ne le
fait pas donc ce sont ces pays qui par
leur législation interne ne le font pas
vous voyez où nous pouvons envoyer les
mineurs non accompagnés il suffit de
changer notre législation nationale